all righty everybody it's time for
tuesday news your bottomless bucket of
good news popcorn shrimp
oh yum
one more
delicious always like 20 more and then
with me at the desk is my number one
news bud rossi ross matthews
[Applause]
i absolutely will first okay first up do
you guys remember that movie 13 going on
30. yeah okay
we'll go down to the rom-com hall of
fame for sure and buzzfeed reports it
stars jennifer garner and mark ruffalo
they are back together on screen in the
new movie the adam projects oh i love
this
and so they're out for that they're
doing some press and they just revealed
they'd both be down for a maddie and
jenna come back for a sequel
and jennifer garner joked it could be
called 50 going on 80.
but i think that's the perfect movie for
a reboot because it's like for starters
it's underrated don't you think and and
like we saw them when they were 13 and
30. now they're what are they like 40
mid 40s and they'd probably have kids by
now you know what i mean yes
and i want to see what their kids would
be
dreaming up in their 30s you know well i
literally quote that movie every day of
my life i love that movie so much i've
watched it for years my daughters love
it
it's a real classic and it has not only
stood the test of time i think it gets
better with each year
more and more people just appreciate it
it it's
it's the best i would totally
love love
and i love when movies have that staying
power you know it does it has classic
staying power it just gets better and
better and better well next up i want to
talk about going to
bed oh how delicious is it at the end of
the day to put on your coziest and
softest pjs and dive right into bed snug
as a bug and a rug well now the question
is you also own a set of the good
pajamas southern living reports that if
you have no idea what that means you
must not be from the south a pair of
good pajamas is a fresh matching set of
pjs that you reserve for special
occasions what would that be let's say a
vacation with friends or your first
sleepover at the in-laws house
[Laughter]
yes what are your favorite pjs and do
you have the good pajamas do you have
mom reserved you have them on tap what's
your pj again well i okay thank you for
asking i'm so i really don't know what
your pj games we've discussed a lot but
we've never discussed our pjs before i
know listen i did not grow up like fancy
so my pajamas were always like old
sweats
it wasn't until adulthood that i had
like grown up pajamas and now i'm i'm
like into it i am so what do you wear at
night rossi thank you so much uh-huh
well i love
i could talk about this all day i love i
didn't know that i love pajamas as much
until wellington is a pajama person he
has like multiple sets that are like
fancy grandma pajamas and so
now i'm i get home and the first thing i
do is i'm like hi gotta go i'm elastic
head to toe you know what i mean
and i have um a pair of my favorite one
is cashmere which is fancy i know we got
it on calm down we got it on sale all
right
it was a clearance pajama but it's like
it's my go-to okay now i gotta ask like
is your little tushy next to the
cashmere or do you wear undies like how
does it work because if i see cashmere
i'm gonna wanna go commando is that
weird
i
i'd like to speak to hr i'm feeling
i'm feeling very uncomfortable
[Applause]
i'm i'm going to lock myself in on
underwear all right i wear underwear
i mean i wear underwear i'm wearing
underwear right now
but sometimes like i'm like i don't want
anything touching me i sleep in the nude
a lot oh never oh really
no i would never sleep in the nude ever
ever ever okay who here would never
sleep in the nude
there's a couple
my luck would be the one night i tried
it there'd be a fire in the house or
something the alarm would go off and i'd
be out front that's why you need a
headlamp in your bedside table
wait okay you are the only one with
rossi what is your name and why would
you never wear
nothing
my name is matthew and i just feel
uncomfortable
i'm with you but what about if you're
like intimate with someone do you then
like put clothes on to like pass out or
is it like okay if you're with somebody
well this is my boyfriend and he sleeps
nude but i just don't like it
[Laughter]
i totally get it yeah well
i'm with you i love sleeping in the nude
i love it so much
what do you love about it air it out
just don't like
tear it out yes oh my gosh
you don't air out you are like a dusty
old sheet not yeah i'm saying
that's like the weirdest combo thank you
apparently guess what it's our mirror
image couple right there there we are
cute something for everyone thank you
guys
[Music]